une file d'attenté pour accéder aux
autres touahri il a rouvert pour des
raisons sanitaires seule la partie
safari qui se fait dans son véhicule
personnel est accessible c'était surtout
de générer un parcours fluide et de
gérer le flux simplement bon paquet soit
d'embouteillages sur la voie publique
soit qui ait pas de stationnement de
rassemblement donc les pique niques et
genre de choses sur notre parking pour
ces jusqu'à jusqu'au 2 jusqu'à la fin du
covin on va dire sera interdit pour
profiter du déconfinement tout en
respectant la règle des 100 km plusieurs
familles ont fait le déplacement sur
internet se chercher ce qu'ils voulaient
se faire parce qu'on habite à côté de
paris
donc ce qui pouvait se faire dans les
environs et c'était une sortie qui est
sympa pour les qui est sympa pour les
enfants parce qu'il adore les animaux
très bien de très agréable de pouvoir
profiter de ça pendant cette période de
deux postes confinement ça fait du bien
en plus c'est dépaysant de voir autant
d'animaux les voitures se succèdent 3000
personnes par jour circulent dans le
safari à thoiry les humains sont
spectateurs des animaux qui vivent eux
en liberté il ya beaucoup de monde ça
ralentit pas mal mais les animaux sont
pas du tout sauvage donc en fait on a pu
voir des autruches carrément qui étaient
garés devant enfin positionné devant
nous donc en fait c'est pas mal on est
carrément dedans et comme on n'avance
pas on a vraiment le panorama tout le
safari du zoo de thoiry sera ouvert pour
le week-end de la pentecôte pour
déambuler de nouveau dans le zoo à pied
il faudra attendre les annonces du
gouvernement le 2 juin